esta vez hablaremos sobre enzimas y en
particular vamos a hablar del efecto del
ph en las enzimas es decir veremos qué
tanto afecta a la actividad enzimática
si el ambiente es ácido o base como
repasó las enzimas son moléculas que
ayudan a catalizar algunas reacciones y
que se encuentran en todos los sistemas
biológicos la mayoría de las enzimas son
proteínas generalmente proteínas grandes
hechas de cadenas de aminoácidos
así que dibujemos una cadena de
aminoácidos donde cada uno de estos
círculos representa un aminoácido la
estructura primaria es una secuencia
también no ácidos pero también existe
una estructura secundaria que explica
cómo este esqueleto de aminoácidos
interactúa consigo misma y mucho de ella
se pasa en los puentes de hidrógeno
entonces tal vez este aminoácido y este
otro forman un puente de hidrógeno y
como repasó un puente de hidrógeno es
una interacción entre el hidrógeno y un
átomo más electro negativo
ejemplo podemos observar esto en el agua
déjame dibujar un par de moléculas de
agua por aquí todo esto es un repaso
recuerda en el agua tenemos estos
enlaces covalentes entre el oxígeno y el
hidrógeno así que posiblemente estas
moléculas están compartiendo electrones
y dado que el oxígeno es más electro
negativo le gusta acaparar más a los
electrones los electrones pasan más
tiempo alrededor de los oxígenos por lo
que esta parte del oxígeno de la
molécula del agua tiene una carga
parcial negativa y esta parte de los
hidrógenos de la molécula del agua tiene
una carga parcial positiva recuerda esta
es la letra griega delta minúscula que
denota parcialidad en este caso es usada
para simbolizar una carga parcial por lo
tanto la parte con carga parcial
negativa es atraída a la parte con carga
parcial positiva de otra molécula y eso
es lo que crea un puente de hidrógeno
aunque ojo no siempre se da entre
oxígeno e hidrógeno de hecho también se
da entre el hidrógeno y el nitrógeno que
es otro átomo electro negativo estos
puentes de hidrógeno no solo nos sirven
para definir la estructura secundaria de
las proteínas que ayudan a dar forma a
la proteína sino que además interactúa
con el sustrato de la proteína es decir
los sustratos que la proteína intenta
catalizar por ejemplo si este gran
círculo rojo es un sustrato parte de él
podrá formar puentes de hidrógeno con la
enzima y si quieres ver una imagen más
compleja de lo que te comento este es un
esquema detallado de un sustrato
interactuando con una enzima aquí puedes
ver que en amarillo tenemos al sustrato
y en rojo a la enzima y puedes ver que
todas estas líneas punteadas son los
puentes de hidrógeno por lo tanto puedes
ver un puente de hidrógeno entre este
hidrógeno y este nitrógeno y un puente
de hidrógeno entre este oxígeno y este
etcétera puedes observar que la enzima
está en volviendo al sustrato ahora
quitando esto del camino cómo influye el
ph bueno tenemos que recordar un poco
que es el ph el p h es el potencial de
hidrógeno de aquí sale la p se define
como el menos logaritmo y todo esto lo
hemos visto en muchas de nuestras clases
de química el menos logaritmo de la
concentración de iones de hidrógeno y un
ión de hidrógeno es esencialmente un
protón ahora cómo afecta a la forma de
la enzima ya su habilidad para poder
interactuar con el sustrato es decir con
la cosa con la que está intentando
actuar bueno depende de cuántos iones de
hidrógeno están flotando alrededor que
muchas veces se encuentran en forma de
hidrógeno que es una molécula del agua
donde el oxígeno está unido a un protón
extra de hidrógeno bueno esto podría
desordenar los puentes de hidrógeno
donde algunos de estos protones de
hidrógeno usurpan la unión
la parte final con carga parcial
negativa de estas moléculas o revelan la
parte final con carga parcial positiva
de estas moléculas en cierta forma
entonces puedes imaginar que diferentes
enzimas deberán tener diferentes niveles
de actividad en diferentes niveles de ph
y ese en efecto es el caso si dibujamos
un diagrama que se ve así en el eje
vertical pondremos a la velocidad de la
reacción donde ésta aumenta mientras
aumentamos en la dirección vertical y en
el eje horizontal tendremos el nivel de
ph y recuerda como el ph tiene este
signo negativo al frente entonces a
mayor concentración de iones de
hidrógeno como el ph es negativo
tendremos menor p h y eso está
relacionado con un ambiente ácido y una
concentración de iones de hidrógeno
menor está relacionada con un ph mayor
una vez más esto pasa por tener el signo
negativo al frente de esta expresión que
nos da una base un ambiente básico y si
tú ph hasta alrededor de 7 entonces
tendremos un ambiente neutro
ahora bien distintas actividades
enzimáticas alcanzan su punto máximo a
distintos ph por ejemplo puedes tener
una enzima como ésta en donde su
actividad enzimática alcance su máximo
en un phd digamos 4 que es relativamente
ácido y puedes ver enzimas de este tipo
en tu estómago donde tienes un ambiente
muy ácido también puedes encontrarte con
otras enzimas que tal vez no tengan
mucha actividad en un ambiente ácido
pero tengan más actividad en un ambiente
neutro por ejemplo en nuestra ocasión
alcanzamos un máximo con un ph de 7 y
luego hay otras enzimas que trabajan
mejor en ambientes más básicos de hecho
podemos ver todo esto en el cuerpo
humano por ejemplo la lipasa es una
enzima que rompe las grasas cuando se
encuentra en el estómago esa versión en
particular de la lipasa alcanza un nivel
óptimo en su actividad enzimática cerca
de un ph como éste de 4
5 después cuando la lipasa es secretada
por el páncreas actúa en el intestino
delgado donde existe un ambiente más
neutro con un ph cercano a 6 o 7 pero el
nivel óptimo en su actividad enzimática
ocurre cerca de un ph de 8 en fin esta
vez lo dejaremos aquí de manera general
muchas veces la forma de la enzima o la
forma en la que actúa con el sustrato
depende de los puentes de hidrógeno
además puedes imaginar que la
concentración de iones de hidrógeno
tiene una influencia en los puentes de
hidrógeno y por esta razón dependiendo
de la enzima o del sustrato con el que
esté actuando en algunas ocasiones
tendrás diferentes reacciones
enzimáticas a diferentes peach es donde
algunas enzimas optimizan su actividad
en ambientes ácidos y otras enzimas
optimizan su actividad en ambientes
neutros o básicos en fin eso es todo por
este vídeo hasta